nueva escena de terror en Estados Unidos
una mujer abrió fuego con dos rifles de
asalto y una pistola en la cube nand
School una escuela cristiana Privada de
Nashville y mató a tres niños y tres
miembros educativos la presunta atacante
fue abatida por la policía
hemos identificado la sospechosa es una
mujer de 28 años Blanca originaria de
Nashville o que vive en la zona
mis hallazgos iniciales es que en un
momento dado ella era un estudiante en
esa escuela pero no estoy seguro En qué
año
si bien las mujeres que disparan de
forma masiva son extremadamente escasas
los tiroteos en centros escolares se han
convertido en algo alarmantemente
frecuentes en los últimos años en
Estados Unidos pero los llamamientos del
presidente Joe biden para que el
congreso restablezca la prohibición
Nacional de los fusiles de asalto se han
topado con la oposición de los
republicanos Defensores acérrimos del
derecho constitucional aportar armas
Es simplemente enfermizo aún estamos
reuniendo las pruebas de lo que sucedió
y porque sucedió sabemos que hay un
número de personas que no van a
sobrevivir incluidos niños es
desgarrador la peor pesadilla
Así que pido al congreso de nuevo que
apruebe mi prohibición de armas de
asalto en lo que va del 2023 se
produjeron 129 tiroteos masivos
definidos Así cuando cuatro o más
personas fueron tiroteadas o asesinadas
según datos del